oh my god
i am so excited to see you i'm very
excited to see you
i have a picture of us actually we did
uh the hollywood reporter round table
like i think it's called like funny
ladies and television funny ladies
talking about very serious issues by the
way it was look at all there's this us
and tracy ellis ross ever messing rachel
brazil in the hands great group
the great molly shannon i adore molly
molly and i have done like four movies
together okay so i have to tell you
that i'm such a romantic and living in
if it's okay to do so
the research and the reverie and the
tone of your relationship with your
husband the great actor dave franco
who is also now
a director and you co-wrote a project
together and your collaborators and your
friends
what's your approach to love because
you're in such a beautiful dynamic thank
you thank you for saying that uh first
of all i'm always happy to talk about
dave and and i
love him so much um i think
a couple things uh you know the first
one is
respect i think that we respect each
other so much and we're so kind to one
another the way we speak like we really
take care with the way that we speak to
one another on a daily basis and it
makes a big difference i think and
also this is sound i don't know
cheesy maybe but but not to hold back
we've never from the day we met each
other
there was there were no games you know
it was like i really like you i like you
too like and every day since then i'm
just like god i am in love with you he's
like i love you too like but there's
something nice about that where i think
people get real guarded and obviously
when you're
you go through different relationships
you have breakups you you have fear
and
and you don't want to get hurt but i'm
sort of like i think it's better to just
go with your instincts and and say it
because wouldn't it be better even to
learn if someone didn't feel the same
way sooner rather than later instead of
feeling like you had to play some game
we don't have enough time to mess around
i can't agree more
i totally agree
first of all it's
important to know efficiently if you are
with your match but
there's a story about how he proposed to
you
is it true that you guys met at mardi
gras yes this gives me hope for mardi
gras
i mean i already thought it was fun but
now i'm like i get me to mardi gras that
one night stand from mardi gras that
i've been with for a decade
can't shake him
so
is it true that
that has a payoff to the story of your
proposal that confused you what happened
please tell us the story well my side of
the story is yes i met him at mardi gras
and basically for 48 hours i wore this
disgusting silver zorro style mask but
like on my custody
i mean awesome but at our 45 you're just
sort of like you didn't you haven't
taken it off at all did you shower um so
at the end of the weekend together i had
written my phone number on the mask and
hidden it in his bag
for him to find he texted me before i
even was at the airport some funny joke
that gave me that feeling you know that
joke someone makes a joke that is like
your style of humor and i was like
oh no i'm gonna fall in love with this
guy
and then i did
so then
cut to we were in big sur for his
birthday weekend so i didn't see it
coming you know what i mean we're not
there to celebrate something romantic
it's about him i have no idea that he's
kept this mask all this time no idea i
thought he wrote down my number and
threw it away
so he tells me we've been down at the
beach in the morning we're covered in
sand and it's one of those classic
moments before a proposal where you're
being lied to and the person's acting
really strange do you know what i mean
he's like come out on the deck we got to
get a photo it's so beautiful right now
i'm like right now i'm i'm disgusting
and sand like and the start of the video
is actually really funny because i don't
know that it's being shot so i'm like
facing away i'm like wiping sand off my
butt it's just my butt it's just like a
full moon while i'm like getting rid of
the sand
and then i turn around finally and he's
just on one knee in a silver zorro mask
with a box
that is not a ring box so he had gotten
a placeholder ring he knew that i wanted
our friend irene north to design my ring
so
he instead he got some placeholder ring
at this antique shop near our house but
the box it came in was just a giant pink
not a ring box i turned around to a
young zorro on one knee with a giant
pink box and i truly was like
like
and he just goes will you marry me and i
was like
what
i started laughing and i was like
are you being serious
and he goes yes this is the mask i've
kept it for five years the day we met i
knew that you were the one and i'm still
cracking up and i'm looking in this box
and the ring
that he bought as a placeholder i love
him i love him
it just looked like a medieval
piece of
corroded metal
do you know that was like black and flat
and weird i like david looked like a
ring so i was standing there
are you being serious and then he
finally goes yes this is just a
placeholder ring i'm gonna have irene
make your ring when we get back to la
and i go yes
[Music]